vous êtes surtout des femmes libres et
bravo après je sais pas si le féminisme
ce résidu vers ses fesses etc ça
d'accord avec vous moi pour moi le
féminisme a montré ses seins ou
s'effacer faire ce qu'on veut juste être
moi je pense le respect de soi même ça
vient par se rendre heureux sans même
c'est personnes forces internes des
photos m'avaient 20 vous aviez à faire
ça j'ai du plaisir à faire ça regarde
bien ça y est j'ai pas besoin de deux
jeux je ne le sais qu'on n'est pas tous
d'accord sur ça et je le respecte
totalement ici mais vous faites des
photos de charme a montré ses fesses et
du tout c'est ainsi le rouge parmi nos
invités c'est l'effet que peut avoir sa
profession sur sa famille chantal avec
son mari adoptez vous paraît que c'est
votre père qui votre manager moi j'ai
des garçons je me pose notamment la
question mais j'essaie de m'imaginer je
suis de votre manager vous êtes messi
est ce que ça crée pas des petites
tensions
non notre père et nous est surtout son
côté qu'on n'est pas manager cette grave
ouais nous est sur le côté business au
delà de tout ça on n'a pas que des
maillots de bain on l'en se plaint
d'être business en ce moment on profite
de notre notoriété pour pour faire ça et
ça c'est notre père qui qui sans
menottes faire la grave et va pas me
dire fait une photo à plus de deux opus
est un an pas dit non c'est une autre
paire a aucun mal à nous voir en maillot
de bain ou un peu dénudée parce qu'ils
nous connaissent
dans la vie réelle et c'est nos valeurs
et c'est ce qu'on essaie de montrer et
c'est qu'on vendait maybin donc en deçà
est compliquée et non hélas aucun mal
avec ça après non il n'a jamais fait
aucun reproche je vous ai choisi de les
vendre comme ça sur ce sur ce type
besoin cette image très sexy et aux
leçons sexy donc on est obligé après
s'est défaussé les maillots sur moi qui
rendent aussi des photos sexy si on
n'est pas une photo avec un boxer
forcément ça serait moins sexy mais je
vois que ça m'intéresse à la hauteur de
collection etc des strings c'est samedi
à connaître en gare mais on ya moins
président mais elle recouvre on voulait
play c'est-à-dire technique là